frédéric bizarre merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors depuis 25
ans la france est un des premiers pays
producteurs de médicaments de l'union
européenne elle est même un des premiers
exportateurs mondiaux
comment peut-on arriver à une telle
situation de pénurie dans les hôpitaux
français
alors c'est vous avez raison on a été le
premier producteur européen pendant
longtemps mais nous avons perdu cette
première place
sur les dix dernières années puisque
nous sommes maintenant numéro quatre en
europe
donc nous nous avons laissé un petit peu
filer notre souveraineté sanitaires sur
le plan des médicaments mais mais pas
uniquement sur le plan des tests y
compris sur le plan d'équipement très
basiques comme les masques ou la vue
qu'on a véritablement des difficultés
d'approvisionnement donc ça c'est le
premier point c'est que nous avons
énormément perdu parce que nous n'avons
pas fait de la santé le l'élément
stratégique le thème stratégique des
politiques publiques
donc nous nous avons laissé filer un
petit peu notre notre leadership en
santé c'est vrai pour la production
industrielle c'est aussi vrai pour les
services de santé on a eu cette ce
classement de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé 2000 qui nous a mis en première
position mondiale
champion du monde en 2000 et et on s'est
un petit peu reposé sur ses lauriers
mais entre temps le monde a
considérablement changé il ya cette
triple transition épidémiologique
démographique et technologique qui fait
que si vous vous adaptez pas c'est un
processus darwinien
eh bien vous vous perdez en
compétitivité très rapidement et c'est
ce qui nous est arrivé
alors pour revenir sur ce risque de
pénurie l'alliance des hôpitaux
universitaires européens a dit avoir
déjà alerté les gouvernements depuis le
la semaine dernière en vain comment est
ce qu'on peut comprendre ce manque de
réaction
alors ça c'est assez facile à comprendre
pour voter les téléspectateurs c'est
c'est assez propre à une épidémie c'est
que l'épidémie contrairement à toute
autre pathologie est un processus
exponentielle qui fait que si vous
n'êtes pas prêt avant le début de
l'épidémie
et si vous ne prenez des dispositions
que lorsque cette épidémie est arrivé eh
bien vous êtes dépassés par la vitesse
de propagation et non par là la vitesse
de demandes que ce soit aux médicaments
on lit de réanimation ou en offre de
services vous vous êtes dépassés parce
que c'est un phénomène exponentiel donc
on a là en europe aujourd'hui une
demande extrêmement forte pour les mêmes
produits qui ne sont pas partis des
produits de ce qu'on appelle la réserve
stratégique 1 donc pour lequel nous il
n'y a pas de ya pas de stocks abondants
et donc tout cesser ces pays se
retrouvent à peu près un même niveau de
maturité de l'épidémie et donc avec un
et une demande qui est qui explosent ou
pour les mêmes produits
donc là il n'y a pas besoin d'être
économiste pour comprendre que forcément
il ya un goulot d'étranglement et que
l'offre de de production n'arrive pas à
faire face il faut savoir que juste pour
cette production est là les deux tiers
des principes actifs de l'ensemble des
médicaments qui sont produits pour
l'europe et pour le reste du monde
proviennent de l'asie est donc là aussi
l'europe n'a pas véritablement pensé de
façon stratégique à sa souveraineté
sanitaires et à laisser les producteurs
les mieux disants en matière de coûts
prendre le contrôle de deux de la source
de leurs médicaments skis et ski qui
sont ces principes actifs et donc là on
en paye le plus fort du coup du coup la
réponse au problème n est pas forcément
européenne non non la réponse à ce
problème là lé paquet européenne elle
est mondiale mais aujourd'hui vous avez
une pandémie qui touche près de 150 pays
donc vous vous imaginez la problématique
à partir des pays asiatiques qui font
aussi de la géopolitique
n'oublions pas que évidemment il ya
toujours de la politique derrière
derrière ça lorsque les chinois vous
approvisionne en prenant en tel type de
produits otc il ya forcément un jeu
politique qui fait que voilà on
approvisionne mais pas suffisamment et
donc vous êtes demandeur et vous restez
quand même dans une position du
demandeur dans une position de faiblesse
politique et ça clairement c'est le sait
ce que paye l'europe aujourd'hui c'est
de ne pas avoir garanti alors qu'elle en
a tout à fait les moyens sur le plan
n'oublions pas que l'europe était quand
même le perso de la médecine pendant des
années pendant des décennies et a laissé
filer ce leadership là et là je crois
que c'est une leçon dont il faudra tirer
toutes les conséquences et du coup en
cas de réquisition des moyens de
production comme comme le demandent à
l'alliance des hôpitaux européens est ce
que vous pensez que la france pourrait
produire suffisamment pour soigner ses
citoyens malades alors produire
suffisamment non sur l'ensemble des
besoins aujourd'hui à l'échelle
européenne en ce qu'il faut d'abord
savoir c'est que on a quand même en
france parce que bon on a quelques
difficultés quand même un petit peu de
coordination entre les différents
secteurs public privé
il faut savoir que cette épidémie à
l'échelle française elle touche de façon
très hétérogène l'ensemble des régions
si vous prenez il ya certaines régions
qui ont une capacité est encore assez
importante qui garde ses produits qui
peuvent manquer dans d'autres régions
parce que évidemment c'est resté région
aujourd'hui peu touchés peuvent être
davantage toucher demain mais à
l'échelle du pays
nous ne sommes quand même pas face à un
risque imminent de pénurie de produits
stratégiques
hormis les produits de protection dont
on dont on a parlé hormis les produits
de dépistage mais concernant ces
produits hospitaliers
il n'y a pas de risque imminent en
france sauf si évidemment cette épidémie
prenez une ampleur équivalente parce que
nous avons aujourd'hui en ile de france
ou dans le grand test sur l'ensemble du
territoire
mais c'est pas le cas et en tout cas les
chiffres d'aujourd'hui montrent que pour
le moment ce n'est pas le cas merci
beaucoup frédéric bizarre d'avoir
partagé votre analyse
sur notre plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste de la santé enseignant à
sciences po et président de l'institut
santé